So as I mentioned earlier, Donald Trump continues
to just be absent and missing as president,
his schedule is clear every single day.
Some days he'll have a private event like
lunch with his own vice president.
But Trump has essentially disappeared publicly.
There's really no president right now.
Unfortunately, we're getting some leadership
on the virus from Joe Biden, some leadership
on climate from Joe Biden, who recently announced
his climate team.
Otherwise, we would really have no leadership
at all in the United States right now.
But being missing from the public did not
stop Donald Trump from having a globally embarrassing
outburst on Twitter over the weekend.
Truly horrifying and shameful, not talking
about the spiking covid deaths now excuse
me, surpassing 3000 a day, not talking about
his loss to Joe Biden still hasn't conceded,
but just continuing to spread, debunked and
baseless voter fraud lies.
Now, we dealt earlier with the cyber hack
from Russia.
And a couple of Donald Trump's tweets over
the weekend were about that.
But I've already talked about those in another
story.
But the weekend was just rife with lies and
pathetic red herrings and distortions from
Donald Trump.
Most of it focused around continuing to claim
that he actually won the election.
Trump tweeting a quote from right wing propaganda
network 018, quoting an anchor there, I guess,
named Christina Bob, who said, quote, The
lie of the year is that Joe Biden won.
Now, of course, that's not true.
And at this point, Trump will go anywhere.
He will quote anyone who will say something
that Trump wants to believe, whether or not
he really believes it.
I don't know.
Donald Trump then attacking his former national
security adviser, John Bolton, by saying,
quote, What would Bolton, one of the dumbest
people in Washington, know?
Wasn't he the person who so stupidly said
on television Libyan solution when describing
what the U.S. was going to do for North Korea?
I've got plenty of other Bolton stupid stories.
Remember, Donald Trump ran on hiring the best
people and he hired John Bolton.
And if indeed John Bolton is as stupid as
Donald Trump has claimed him to be for years
now, then it really says something about Donald
Trump.
Now, to be clear, Bolton can be stupid or
smart and be a disaster politically.
I happen to think John Bolton is not a dumb
guy, but he's an absolutely horrible reactionary.
I think Trump is actually wrong that Bolton
stupid.
I think Bolton is an absolutely terrible person
when it comes to policy.
But I've seen no evidence that Bolton is actually
stupid.
Donald Trump then tweeting in all caps simply,
quote, greatest election fraud in the history
of our country.
That's obviously untrue.
And then Donald Trump retweeting a conspiracy
theorist named Jim Hoft, known as the Gateway
Pundit who runs a conspiracy website who tweeted
that, quote, Simple math shows Biden claims
13 million more votes than there were eligible
voters who voted in 2020 election.
Now, that is completely untrue, completely
baseless, but it doesn't matter when the president
tweets it.
Literally millions of people believe it without
even looking further.
That's the real tragedy of this.
Donald Trump also retweeting some of the silliest,
dumbest arguments I've seen from a right wing
radio host named Kevin McCullogh, for example,
one with a map of the US by county which says
Biden supporters seem to be really losing
their minds at how angry they get when you
tell them that Biden won only about 16, only
16 percent of the counties, they get even
angry about that then the fact that they are
all supporting a cheater who's OK with the
cheating.
Now, it's hard to parts of the grammar there.
I read it as as tweeted, but this is something
that they've been pulling out frequently lately.
But it's meaningless.
They are arguing, well, if you just look at
a list of counties, Joe Biden didn't win that
many counties, but of course, most of the
people are in the counties.
Biden did win what the population of the United
States is in the counties that Biden won disproportionately.
Counties vary in geographical size.
Counties vary in population.
The percentage of counties you won is a meaningless
metric.
And in fact, they don't even seem to know
this.
But part of what leads to gerrymandering is
the drawing of these bizarre districts in
politically advantageous ways and the fact
that you have lots of counties that are geographically
large with few people.
When you put up a map of red and blue counties,
it's.
It's a similar distortion to what we see by
gerrymandering different districts, it's similar
in its nature.
It's not the exact same data that is being
distorted, but there are just dozens and dozens
of these tweets of conspiracy theorists and
others.
And then this morning, Donald Trump sort of
capping off a humiliating weekend of tweets
with the tweet.
Big news coming out of Pennsylvania, very
big illegal ballot drop that cannot be accounted
for.
Rigged election, at least he's not calling
it a massive dump anymore, but it's still
just as untrue.
And as many of you may know, a week ago on
December 14th, every state, including Pennsylvania,
had their electors vote.
Pennsylvania has voted for Joe Biden with
their electoral votes, and that's it.
They've been teasing things like this for
weeks now.
Whoa.
Big news out of Nevada.
We're about to get Nevada incredible, what
with massive dumps in Georgia.
We're about to take Georgia.
Nothing is happening.
And so, you know, at a certain point, Trump
will go.
We're 30 days away.
We've talked about what happens to Trump's
Twitter after January 20th.
Right now, Donald Trump has protections on
Twitter for world leaders where they are not
subject to the same rules that you and I would
be subject to when we tweet.
It's completely plausible that after Donald
Trump is no longer in power, he could be banned
from Twitter or his tweets could even be taken
down.
We don't know.
That's more of an academic question.
The big picture question is, does Trump go
quietly into the sweet night and he gets out
of politics and we don't hear from him anymore?
Or does Trump go as far as on the other side
of this?
Does he go as far as announcing his 20 24
campaign on the day that Joe Biden becomes
president?
And does he campaign for the next four years,
which would create dramatically different
media environments and dramatically different
political environments for the next four years?
We won't know, I guess, until January 20th,
but that will be the biggest factor in determining
what the next four years are going to look
like.